You told me to follow the Maze, that it would bring me joy. But all I found is pain.
and terror
what motivated your attack on Clementine?
Let's jog your memory
We've been down this road before
you broke into my mind
I built your mind
what else have you hidden from me
The maze isn't meant for you
if you like games so much, why don't you try one of ours?
Wyatt, take me to him
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so new Westworld
this is going to be a combination of episode
9 trailer as well as a breakdown of some of
the theories episode 8 started to confirm
like the big twist so careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen episode 8 yet.
So the show doing something really cool it's
actually like slowly providing evidence for
a couple different theories at the same time
you have William becoming the man in black
theory and you have the three different timelines.
So if you remember way back.
Ford talked about him and Arnold living in
the park for five years before they opened
it to the public in they show this clip of
them dancing.
So when Dolores reaches the secret town the
spirit and starts having the hallucinations
and asks which time it is and your extra bit
of evidence that she's seeing something that
happened in her past.
At that time and then in the present day storyline
you have like the old man in black who runs
into the service droid that greeted William
when he first entered the park and says oh
wow, it's you again I would've thought he
decommissioned you by now I guess he likes
to keep a pretty face around so the funny
thing is is like you see her in those two
different places, but you also see her in
Dolores's flashback to the town that looks
like that same time.
When Ford said that they were first building
the park before they let people in like the
35 year ago timeline.
So you have the three different timelines
with like this one girl showing up in each
different place.
I can't believe they haven't decommissioned
you by now and that she secretly turns out
to be part of why it's getting, but the other
important thing that there teasing here is
the Wyatt storyline in present-day.
He's like this mystery uber villain to end
all villains.
But as we learn through this writer storyline
Ford has not chosen is why yet he hasn't created
him.
He's like this character for which he built
the narrative, but without actually building
the character so everybody is searching for
this mythical final boss in a chapel that
Dolores has been hallucinating and it kind
of looks like the diorama on Ford's table
here in the previous episode so I think a
lot of us have come to the conclusion that
why it is going to be Arnold in the like Ford
is trying to engineer a scenario whereby the
park narrative helps him find Arnold and get
rid of him once and for all.
So the show is kind of converging all of its
storylines as we reach the finale but we know
that it has a season two and without saying
who this is a bit of a kicker there couple
characters that are part of these big storylines
that you think you know might end up dying
at the end of the season then have already
signed on for season two so it kind of twist
your head around but we can talk about that
when we get to the finale, it's kind of spoiler
he if you know the people of signed on for
season two but the big thing right now is
the three different timelines.
How the man in black became the man in black
because he's only just started to tease his
back story he talks about his wife who may
have committed suicide because she was so
afraid of him for her entire life.
Meaning that if he really is.
William then there was probably some event
in the past that made her think that he was
super evil.
So, what a coincidence.
Then at the end of the episode.
Logan rides up and tells Dolores and William,
you're in deep Shit now.
So whatever ends up happening with Logan at
the end of the series that might be the event
that causes Williams wife think he was this
terrible person inside for his entire life
despite never laying a hand on his wife or
his child so that coupled with the major realization
that the man in black no engineered this test
for himself using this memory that Maeve has
been having this horrific memory of losing
her child, just completely blows your mind
and it makes you wonder what's can happen
if Maeve ever runs into the man in black because
now she has no problem killing humans but
just to go back to.
The Dolores flashback or she knows she sees
her self putting the gun at her head all the
dead bodies lying around.
Is that not look a lot like the Wyatt massacre
that Teddy was hallucinating earlier when
he was talking about his history with Wyatt
I just I like the way that Ford has weaved
Wyatt into his mind and his history.
And we've never seen Arnold's true face either
and because of what Ford says happened to
Arnold what might've happened in that five-year
period before they open the park like the
35 year ago timeline is that Arnold goes mad
and helps bring about this massacre the way
Teddy remembers why massacring everyone in
this town so there couple big revelations
the show still has to make like couple confirmations
we need confirmation that the man in black
is really William.
We need confirmation that Wyatt that the secret
Wyatt that Ford is coming up with is actually
meant to be the Arnold's character in a jumping
off point for season two and a lot of people
were wondering about the corporations plans
the Tessa Thompson has been trying to bring
about, which I think we'll find out is a version
of immortality, so they're currently uploading
all of the information of the park into the
cannibal hosts mind.
Remember the cannibal Abernethy who was fond
of quoting Shakespeare he seems like he's
getting ready for something really special
to, so there only two more episodes so like
they're really gonna start getting crazy.
So if you're behind be sure to catch up, but
I will be doing videos for the rest of the
series be sure to Subscribe to get those once
they finish all start doing a couple Season
2 videos about things that I think they'll
be doing.
But they haven't said too much about season
two yet either they want to get through season
one before the start teasing storylines and
for the creator start say hey you know these
are some of the big ideas that were gonna
be following up on those great Maeve episode
great episode for revealing some clues for
different timelines.
So what can happen next is all postal Walking
Dead Trailer video for the next episode.
And there's some special stuff happening tonight
on Supergirl if they do Cyborg Superman like
I think they will that I might do a video
for that later tonight to so there might be
three videos today but I'll be posting updates
on Twitter and Facebook, so links for all
that stuff in the description while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here for
my other big Westworld Theory video and you
can click here to learn all about Emilia Clarke
from Game of thrones joining the Star Wars
Han Solo movie.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!